yes hi I'm Jonathan redford CEO of
Habitat for Humanity International and
delighted to greet you from the World
Economic Forum I've been asked by Alan
waters off for facebook please tell us
what you care about what the future
direction you seek and how you will
contribute to the future a state of the
world and Alan what I would say is I
care a lot about affordable housing and
I'm delighted that that has slowly
become part of the agenda for the World
Economic Forum and Habitat for
Humanity's vision is that everyone in
the world I should have a decent place
to live and we do that by bringing
people together to build homes and
communities and hope off the idea that
if you don't have a decent place to live
children don't stay healthy they don't
get educated they don't have a chance to
bring themselves up out of poverty and
so my hope is that said at these
discussions both housing and the issue
rapid urbanization will be heavily in
the agenda this year and that we will
change hearts and minds so that poverty
housing and homelessness become socially
politically and religiously unacceptable
in our nation's in world thank you